i'm greg jarrett i'm sandra smith i'm
charles payne and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday june 23 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
migrants continue to arrive at the u.s
mexico border and border state counties
law enforcement and landowners say
they're overwhelmed every single law
enforcement
person we've talked to whether it's
border patrol a state trooper a county
sheriff they're all saying the same
thing they have never seen it this bad
in their entire lives i'm dave anthony
a pandemic trend is reversing
more people are returning to the office
no longer working from home
but not all people are deciding that who
they were pre-pandemic is not who they
want to be moving forward they may want
a total lifestyle change
and that could be where they live that
could be where they work
people are in some cases really changing
their minds about things and i think
it's a little hard to go back
and i'm rachel campos-duffy i've got the
final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
historically high numbers of migrants
continue to come to the u.s mexico
border
border agents reported more than 180 000
contacts with migrants at the southern
border in may up
from 178 000 in april and while fewer
children have been coming as of late
family units and especially single
adults still arrive in droves vice
president kamala harris who's been
tasked with addressing the root causes
of migration
traveled to mexico and guatemala earlier
this month i want to be clear
to folks in this region who are thinking
about making
that dangerous track to the united
states mexico border
do not come do not come
some border state governors have had
enough saying their counties are being
overrun they blame a lack of action from
the federal government
and insists that harris needs to visit
the border to understand the issue
texas governor greg abbott and arizona
governor doug ducey signed a border
state pact over the surge
and abbott said last week texas will
build
a border wall in our state
to help secure our border he asked for
other states to send help in the form of
personnel and said the goal will be to
have state
county and city law enforcement make
border related arrests
using trespassing laws saying that
counties along the border are being
overrun with migrants
you have these big groups of like 50 to
100 venezuelans just walking across the
rio grande led by a smuggler
bill malusion is a fox news
correspondent who's been at the border
in the rio grande valley sector for
several weeks now
who has no fear at all of being caught
you know he just walks the people across
the river
drops him off on the american side just
feet away from law enforcement
and has no fear of being caught and then
we saw the exact same thing happening
here on
friday night we went out on a state
trooper ride-along in roma texas
right here in the rio grande valley and
we were watching human smugglers
using rafts to literally do a shuttle
service for migrants from the mexican
side of the river
to the american side of the river and
just dropping them off right in front of
national guard right in front of border
patrol
right in front of state troopers and the
smugglers
were very confident very brazen they
were laughing they were making jokes
they took their head coverings off
they were not afraid of being caught and
i talked to a state trooper and said you
know why are you guys not
not going after one of these smugglers
they're just feet away from you guys and
they're they're coming to the american
side
they said because it's a safety issue
for the migrants essentially
they're worried that if they try to make
a move on one of these guys
because they're shuttling women and
young children
they'll take it out on the migrants and
they'll flip the rafts over or they'll
dump people in the water
and instead of trying to get the
smugglers they'll turn it into
you know a rescue operation trying to
save these migrants so
it's kind of a lose-lose situation i i
follow your twitter feed
uh regularly you have some just insane
pictures and and storytelling going on
there
um you you wrote on in one post that
people actually asked you to call the
border patrol for them
you have other shots of smugglers just
fearing people across
hour after hours you said and other
pictures of just
men packed into the back of these
enclosed trucks
in like over 100 degree heat i mean this
is
overwhelming to see i imagine
yeah no it absolutely is some i guess
one of the more wild things was on
tuesday of last week in
alton texas which is like 20 minutes
north of where we are
um we got tipped off to a human
smuggling stash house bust
and we got there right as border patrol
and state troopers were
were breaking it up and there were 107
migrants
who were being kept at that stash house
and there was no air conditioning there
was only one restroom
it's scorching hot and humid out here in
texas they were all crammed on top of
each other
and what the cartels do what the
smugglers do is they bring these folks
into the country and then they'll
they'll put them in these stash houses
cram them on top of each other and
they'll hold them there
until they're ready to move them further
into the interior of the united states
and what was wild about this one was
spray painted
in graffiti on the wall of the stash
house where the letters cdg
which law enforcement sources tell us
stands for cartel del golfo which is the
gulf cartel
and that's the mexican drug cartel that
operates in the reynosa area in the
mexican side of the border south of
where we are right now
and they're big into both human
smuggling and drug trafficking and yes
when you
a couple times this week we had large
groups of migrants just approach
us and there were no border patrol
anywhere because they're they're
stretched so thin they can't be
everywhere at once
um so yeah the the migrants come up to
us can say
where where don't they establish where's
border patrol and we're we have to be
like uh we we don't know
they might be here soon um but it kind
of just goes to show
um you know just how overwhelmed and
undermanned border patrol is in this
sector because rio grande valley is
totally overrun right now
and it's the busiest sector along the
entire u.s mexico border
it brings up another point bill and that
is that there are sort of two groups it
feels like and you can correct me if i'm
wrong
of people who want to announce
themselves they want to claim asylum
they want to go through some process
knowing that they will be allowed to
stay in the united states
pending their case and another group of
people who absolutely do not want to get
caught and scurry across
you know at night or in a in a way of
to hide um which group do you do you
sense is bigger
and who's falling into which category i
imagine the people who are coming who
don't want to announce themselves maybe
either have a record here
maybe have you know uh for some reason
obviously don't want
to to claim asylum and go through a
process and be on the books
there's a very clear distinction going
on between the folks coming over there
are
the family units the moms the kids
the folks who are all willing to just
turn themselves in they come here and
they are looking for border patrol
because they want to give
themselves up that's the overwhelming
majority of what we're seeing then on
the other hand
you've got the runners and the folks who
do not want to be caught and typically
what happens is when those family units
come across and give themselves
the smugglers and the cartels will send
send those family units over
and then they know border patrol
responds to them and they got to process
you know 100 people at a time
and it sucks up their resources so while
that's happening
then they'll send the people who do not
want to be caught elsewhere along the
border and that's when
those runners will come across so we've
got in recent weeks some pretty wild
video from our fox drone
of those runners literally just making a
run on the border just taking off
running in all directions as border
patrol
is trying to chase them down they're
able to catch some of them but not all
of them
i know bill aside from migrants you have
talked to some elected officials you've
talked to sheriff's officials law
enforcement not just the law enforcement
at the border in terms of border patrol
but
more inland right you know the the
county operators and also maybe
state officials what what are they
telling you
what's most striking to you about what
they're sharing with you
so universally every single law
enforcement
person we've talked to whether it's
border patrol a state trooper a county
sheriff they're all saying the same
thing they have never seen it this bad
in their entire lives and they they
believe it's going to get worse
because they think title 42 is going to
get dropped pretty soon
because title 42 is of course what the
government is using to
expel people from the country based off
covet 19 precautions while as
vaccination numbers go up and things
start reopening and the ports of rent
of of entry start reopening there's no
longer going to be a justification to
expel people
on the basis of covet 19. now some state
governors have responded to the request
from governors abbott and ducey to send
resources
florida's governor ron desantis said he
would send law enforcement personnel
so did the governor of nebraska pete
ricketts what we've seen with the bidet
administration is really an utter
disregard
for the security of our nation by
rushing to undo the trump-era policies
that have reduced illegal immigration
along our southwest border
and we can see now that we've got an
immigration crisis there
in may was 180 000 contacts of people
trying to cross illegally
if you can trust contrast that to may of
2020
it was 23 000 so a significant increase
and if you want to look back to the
previous records 144 000. so we've never
seen this kind of
illegal immigration across our southwest
border and that does not
impact just the border states it impacts
all states
as we see illegal immigrants then
continue to spread out across our
country
and so the state of nebraska received a
request from texas to be able to help
out through our emergency management
system
and we are sending 25 state patrol
troopers
down for a period of 16 days to be able
to help out in the del rio area with
law enforcement operations to be able to
help the state of texas
manage this huge illegal crossing
at our borders you said it impacts all
states the fact that that people are
coming that this many people are coming
do you
do you guys in nebraska have a large
population of undocumented folks you
know why are you invested here we
actually had a
situation in one of our rural towns
where we had a number of folks who would
come here illegally being
really extorted and taken advantage of
by the fact that they were here
illegally
you know having their paychecks
intercepted you know having their
paychecks
basically skimmed so that they weren't
getting full value for what they were
working and that's just one example of
the human cost that goes along
with people coming here illegally and we
can also see it through the huge number
of
un accompanied minors that are crossing
the border
uh you know there was an article in our
paper about a
father from honduras who tried to cross
was caught uh returned and then sent his
seven-year-old daughter
uh ahead uh without him you know that
kind of thing is just
a human tragedy and it was all
precipitated by the byte administration
and their bad policies so we as the
state feel like we have to step up where
the federal government is failing
governor abbott's talking about you know
making arrests building a wall even
i think he's even asked private property
owners to donate their land to that
effort
and we've heard this debate before that
immigration and border defense you know
is under federal
not state purview so what happens here
legally can this even get done these
sorts of efforts like building a wall
at the state level or is it maybe a
waste of time and money to even try this
will it legally hold up
well the fact of the matter is we have
an immigration crisis
on this border and governor abbott's
team i'm sure is
more versed in what they want to
accomplish we're providing some of the
extra manpower to
serve them through this emergency
management request so i would defer to
their team with regard to this but it's
there's no doubt federal government has
really dropped the ball the byte
administration is not doing its job
uh vice president harris who is supposed
to be in charge of this hasn't even
bothered to visit the border
so this is a huge failure on the federal
government's part
and that leaves states left to trying to
come up with whatever solutions they
can to be able to stem these sorts of
crises
the binding administration has argued
that that vice president harris's
i guess project or goal here
is to handle and tackle long-term
uh migration issues like the root causes
of these
migration issues but a lot of folks and
you've seen them too republican congress
people going to the border
sort of angry that that vice president
harris hasn't visited the border why is
it so important in your mind
to see the the what's happening for
yourself like
why did the president or the vice
president need to actually go to the
border in order to deal with this
problem
because they could i imagine do a number
of things
that maybe even you would be happy with
on this and to tackle this issue without
actually
seeing it right well certainly looking
at the long-term causes is going to be
important
but as an executive you need to see
firsthand
what the short-term crisis is to be able
to help cut through some of the red tape
this is something i've learned
as an executive over the course of the
last six and a half years in office as
governor
and it's clear that the white
administration does not have that
executive
experience to understand what they need
to do
to be able to not only assess the
situation but also show
support for the people who are on the
front line right now
they are being overwhelmed and they need
to know
that their executive
their commander-in-chief is going to be
there to be able to have their back and
that has been
lacking that has not happened governor
pete ricketts thank you so much for your
time
great hey thank you very much for having
me on
[Music]
this is rachel campos-duffy with your
fox news commentary coming up
we get the next employment report next
week
for june the month before 559
000 jobs were created prompting
president biden to boast
the economy has momentum were on the
right track
but hiring has been less than expected
in may and april
and nine million people remain out of
work and there are almost as many job
openings
with republicans claiming three hundred
dollars a week in extra federal
unemployment benefits that
26 states are ending are to blame for
people not
wanting to work gop congresswoman
marionette miller meeks told fox just
the other day
very troublesome for small businesses
troublesome for families trying to
get by uh you know coming out of the
pandemic so i think that there is a lot
of concern
one trend in all this more people who
work from home in these coveted times
are back in the office well for starters
38
of americans worked from home at some
point since the pandemic was declared
in march 2020. ted rossman is a senior
industry analyst for bankrate.com 32
percent
started working from home because of
covid another six percent
already worked from home so among that
roughly one-third of americans who
started working at home
during the pandemic 45 of them
are still working from home full time
but a little over half have gone back to
the office
it's very split though 27 back in the
office full time
28 back in the office part of the time
it really depends a lot on the industry
the employer i would tell you though
that i've actually been surprised how
many people
are going back to the office relatively
quickly
we've seen a big uptick here in the past
few weeks and months and
i actually think that working from home
will probably be a perk for the lucky
few
moving forward i think that by and large
most people are headed back to the
office
most of the time you know maybe you can
wrangle a day or two a week
at home but i'm sensing a pretty strong
return to the office culture
there was a lot of zoom fatigue that
happened for a while people were kind of
sick
of of that but at the same time
the not having to go through the daily
grind of commuting
certainly was a plus for many of these
workers who
may have to go back and deal with the
commute again
it was huge financially and more
intangibly in terms of
the benefits of less stress and more
family time more freedom more sleep
you know specifically on the financial
side 57 percent of people who worked
from home
during covid said that it actually
helped their finances and only 10
said it was negative and the biggest
positives that i see
are the commute for sure food clothes
child care i think there's a lot of
financial benefits to working from home
that though is for a certain
section of the workforce maybe the white
collar
side people who were rather in the
higher income area to begin with right
that's exactly how it broke down yeah so
only about a third of americans started
working from home
during covid by and large it was higher
income households 54
with annual household incomes over 80
000
a year worked from home at some point
during the pandemic
there's about half of that for middle
income households
and it was only 21 of households that
make under forty thousand dollars a year
so it did tend to be
higher income folks and the age
breakdown
is interesting too we actually find that
young adults so gen z and millennials
they're the more likely to say that
it saved them money working from home
when it comes to
those workers as well they seem to like
the remote work more than
say the boomers right in some respects
it's kind of a mixed bag because you
know i mentioned that young adults said
that they
saved the most money working from home
right we also find though that
young adults are the most likely to
already be back
in the office and i think there's some
element of
to each their own somebody who's more
extroverted
somebody who maybe lives alone they
might be more eager to get back into the
office
early career workers too they benefit
for more from that mentor mentee kind of
relationship it's a total mixed bag
though because we also had baby boomers
that were the most likely to tell us
that they missed
the networking and the camaraderie of
the office so i think that
it's a little bit hard to paint with too
broad of a brush on this one because i
do think it's very
individualized to your personality
where you live what industry you work in
i'm seeing that financial companies are
more likely to be calling people back
whereas
companies are more likely to say that
work from home could be here to stay
i think it's something that could be
very negotiable moving forward
that just like you might negotiate your
salary and your vacation time
negotiating some kind of work from home
arrangement could be attractive for some
whereas other people just can't wait to
get back into the office you know i've
heard anecdotes and
people that i know who have been dealing
with
some people at work who are fighting the
return
uh and also how it's been difficult for
some companies to attract
workers if they're not flexible if they
say you have to come to an office that
it's making it tougher for them to find
people who want to do that i've heard
that too
some people have moved you know in
particular to lower cost parts of the
country
where if you can draw a big city salary
and live somewhere with a lower cost of
living
and work remotely oh sure when
child care is also a big wild part in
this because
on the face of it you would think that
working from home helps lower your
child care expenses but especially if
you have young kids they may still need
a lot of supervision
now we're heading into summer vacation
but even when schools were open
in some cases it was hybrid or fully
remote so i think the pandemic is having
a lasting effect
on child care and and i think it could
also be a great reset in the sense of
some people are deciding that who they
were pre-pandemic is not who they want
to be
moving forward they may want a total
lifestyle change and that could be
where they live that could be where they
work people are
in some cases really changing their
minds about things and i think it's a
little hard to go back
i could tell you personally i commuted
an hour and a half each way
and i haven't done that in more than a
year and it really is a big time saving
it's unbelievable to not have to spend
two or three hours a day
in the car and not only that it's not
just the time in the car it's
it's the quality of the time in the car
if you're if you're stressed out with
traffic
it's a huge win for some people i really
like the work from home lifestyle i'm
mindful of the fact that not everybody
thinks that way even at my company
there's some people that
can't wait to go back and there's going
to be a voluntary reopening soon because
that's the other thing is that
employers are still struggling with the
covet side of this well
we're thankful for vaccines and we've
seen rapid improvement
it's still kind of a gray area legally
where what can you require
can you make people get vaccinated
probably not
can you ask if they've been vaccinated
you know even that can be a little bit
of a squishy area
so what i think a lot of companies are
doing is more of the soft opening and
it's kind of
if you want to come back we're here if
you're not we'll give you a little more
time
i think we're kind of in this in between
right now i think
by the fall and certainly by the turn of
the year
we may see some more progress on this
but
yeah right now there are some people who
can't wait to get back there's some
people who never want to go back
some people are leaving their jobs
because they've really become accustomed
to this new lifestyle and
they say i don't want to spend 40 50 60
hours a week in the office anymore
so i really think that this will have
some broader ripple effects for the job
market
and even for things like housing
what about though office space
like in the cities where people have
been commuting to if fewer
people go to the office companies don't
need as much space
so what does that do for the commercial
real estate market i mean landlords
it's not a good time it could save
companies a lot of money
if they can get out of these leases
that's the thing a lot of these
corporate leases are very long
term so you might not be able to just
flick a switch but yeah some companies
can realize savings
that really hurts landlords and the
commercial side of things
you think about also all the
infrastructure dry cleaners you know
other people that kind of support the
office work
directly or indirectly cleaning services
would be another example
yeah there's definite ripple effects
here i think some companies are calling
people back
in part because they feel like we've got
all this base we might as well use it
and there is a control element to having
your staff
on site there can be benefits too i
think the hybrid model
may work for a lot of people and it may
require some different
choices like for example if the staff is
only in the office three or four days a
week
maybe those are the days that are more
communal maybe those are the days that
you have more meetings and you get
people together and
then the days that are more independent
work well maybe that you can just do
from home
we may see mondays and fridays become
big work from home days
but i do think that we're seeing a lot
more returning to the office now
than we projected even a few months ago
those workers returning to offices
is good news for cities that miss their
commuters like new york
which has more crowded subways and buses
also probably because more people are
vaccinated and feel safer using public
transportation
now the mta reports subway and bus and
commuter rail passenger numbers hit
pandemic highs last friday but
that's only about half the ridership
before covid still it is
much needed revenue and more office
workers is also good for
city restaurants that rely on the
business lunch crowd
very important yeah i think that that is
an area that has been struggling and
will probably be slower to bounce back i
think on a similar note
we could talk about business travel we
could talk about conferences
and trade shows and we're just starting
to see really the early stages of some
of the
recovery there because that's the other
thing that just because something is
open
doesn't mean people are necessarily
going to go to it
you might be more likely to go into the
office and
work in small groups or work by yourself
as opposed to
doing a big team lunch or conference or
trip or something like that so i do
think that there's going to be kind of
an uneven
pace to this what about the workforce
that
never could work from home you know
there's a lot of people who have jobs
it's impossible
to do them from home has there been any
resentment from them to people who've
been able to stay home and it seems like
they're having a fun time
you know that's an interesting point i
mean there certainly could be uh we're
thankful for
so many aspects of this improvement and
the reopening
but yeah it's been such a difficult time
for people that work in restaurants and
other
in-person settings that have really been
hurt by this so
i'm sure if you run a restaurant or you
work in a restaurant in a
central business district i'm sure
you're hoping that everybody comes back
and spends money and tips generously and
ultimately this is really an intertwined
ecosystem but
something that we found on many fronts
during the pandemic is that
inequality has been exacerbated we've
seen that with who's able to work from
home we've seen that with
job losses it's been very uneven
and i think that this has really
amplified some existing
trends but clearly if you're a a
well-paid
work from home office type worker your
finances are probably better now than
they were
pre-pandemic because you've been saving
more spending
less still been banking a healthy salary
sadly there are many at the other end of
the spectrum who've really struggled
through this
so um you know i think there will be
winners and losers
and it kind of remains to be seen how it
all shakes out
ted rossman senior industry analyst at
bankrate.com we thank you very much for
joining us
thanks for having me
fox nation presents podcasts women of
the bible speak
i'm shannon breme host of fox news at
night and author of the new book
women of the bible speak the wisdom of
16 women and their lessons for
today subscribe now on apple podcast
spotify foxnewspodcast.com or wherever
you
download your podcast it's time for your
fox news commentary
rachel campos duffy what's on your mind
when i hosted fox news primetime on fox
news channel
i interviewed an amazing guest named
helen
rally riley grew up in china and wrote a
very thoughtful piece in the federalists
after woke liberals
decided to cancel dr seuss when rally
immigrated to the united states
from china one of the things she most
loved about america
was children's literature she loved how
american children's stories were full of
optimism they were fun and whimsical
and they encouraged children to dream
and use their imagination
it was so different from the dark
ideologically marx's children's stories
she was exposed to in communist china as
a chinese immigrant
helen is deeply worried that political
correctness
cancel culture and the woke gatekeepers
of america's publishing world
are cultivating the same propaganda
literature of remarx's homeland
one of the few silver linings of the
pandemic is that parents of all
political persuasions across
america are beginning to wake up to the
indoctrination their children are being
exposed to
through teachers librarians textbooks
cartoons movies and social media
frustrated
and feeling helpless parents are finally
starting to show up to school board
meetings
they're pulling their kids out of woke
schools that were teaching them to hate
their country
each other and if they are white
themselves
this is all good but as parents focus on
their schools
and the usual hollywood and big tech
suspects
the gatekeepers of america's children's
literature publishers editors
and big box bookstores like amazon and
barnes and mobile
fly under the radar they're the ones
that decide what gets published
canceled or suggested when you are
shopping
for children's books online only liberal
authors who meet the narrow
woke definition of diversity are
published or promoted
for them inclusion ironically does not
include
authors who don't agree with their
politics or worldview
books with traditional or conservative
messages are deliberately excluded
most troubling is that today in the name
of racial and historical sensitivity
books that are culturally important to
america ones that once shaped our
children's minds such as
the adventures of huckleberry finn to
kill a mockingbird
and yes dr seuss are being canceled
and outright banned as an avid lifelong
collector of children's books and a mom
who loves to read your own children
rallies answers to this disturbing trend
resonated with me
one solution she explained is to create
your own
freedom library at your home how do you
start
it's easy says rally start with all the
books progressives want to ban
with america's librarians and amazon's
jeff bezos leading the charge in
literary censorship
i suggest quickly purchasing those
little treasures you grew up reading and
loving quickly
before some make work diversity
non-profit decides that
treasure island or nancy drew are too
offensive during our prime time
interview i asked riley to give me
her list of books for a freedom library
in addition i have my own list to add to
her essential
children's books that every parent or
grandparent
should introduce to the young curious
and impressionable minds in their lives
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes